well I'm joined in the studio by a
former senior British Military
Intelligence officer Philip Ingram
um okay let's uh talk our viewers
through all of this then what does the
movement of Russian forces out of the
Hearthstone region tell us do you think
well it's quite significant and they've
got the ability to do that because of
what we're seeing in this picture here
the danipa river the flooding that's
there has meant that it's almost
impossible for the ukrainians to put any
military force across the donipo river
but I'm very unlikely in first place but
now we're in the impossibility sticks
and that get that frees up the Russian
troops that were protecting that
Harrison region and allows them to be
reconstituted and moved up as a reserve
Force so it's quite a big area they've
had some of the best combat troops in
there they're taking them and they're
putting them up as reserves into where
the ukrainians are are attacking in
through zaparizia and up towards donesk
and elsewhere so it's that Reserve
that's that's giving the Russians
additional military capability
so then what does president zielinski
mean by the counter-offensive has begun
well I think everyone looks at the the
Hasbro gun is the grime
counter-offensive because it's been
going on for weeks just shipping the
battle space the drones over Moscow the
belgugrada incursion the attacks into
um oil refineries and elsewhere and then
command and control bunkers and
Logistics sites but the ground attacks
have have happened so we've had that
preparation there's been probing along
this hundreds of kilometers of front
line that aren't subject to flooding and
now we're getting some some penetrating
attacks in um attacks into backwood
um there's unconfirmed reports that
they've taken over a kilometer of
territory back to the north of backwood
a tax down Southeast of Donetsk
um and there's again unconfirmed reports
of some successes there and then what
seems to be an emerging main effort
which is from zaparasia down through
auricive through Tom Mack and
potentially Don demilio Paul splitting
the land lines of communication the
roads and rail links from Crimea up in
to that disputed donbass region which
will unseat the whole of the rationale
for the Russians wanting to be there
and of course the vulgar group have been
a big dominant force in all of this uh
the the mercenary group has today said
that it won't sign a contract with the
Russian defense Ministry what more do we
know about them well yes um pregosian um
on the left here who had the Wagner
group who used to be a friend of
Vladimir Putin
um he has never been a friend of shogu
the defense minister and never been a
friend of grazimov General who's
commanding the operations inside
um Ukraine however maintaining his
military capability know that they're
not fixed in bakmutan fighting there are
potentially gives a political risk of
Vladimir Putin defense minister has
turned around and said that everyone is
designed a permanent contract and join
the Russian military normally by the
first of July progression has said no
Philip Ingram thank you very much indeed